well for people who are joining this
meeting this is a kickoff of an
exploration of something for future
versions of language related to drawing
tools and the basic background is we
have had this drawing tools palette for
ever and very few people use it because
it has turned out not to be as usable as
we'd hoped so let's take a look here um
so the idea is just like if we have an
image right if we have a rare oh we get
a good random image um let's say 400 400
here if we click the image we get up
this attached cell here that gives us
various tools which I have to say I
think are pretty useful um
comments from people I mean I think this
pattern seems to work fairly well we
don't support this in the cloud at this
time and Matt I don't know if you know
anything about that effort to support
that in the cloud we haven't had as a
priority right is it knowing to be very
difficult or is it is what's the issue I
don't think we ever looked into it
yeah I could for that off and we could
look into it fine okay
this hasn't been a lot of interest I
mean my guess would be that it's not
difficult but I mean that no individual
part of it is hard but that you know
there's probably a lot of stuff that it
does that isn't supported and cloud yet
right okay but let's talk about the I
mean yes I agree that an attached cell
is the kind of the only way this is
going to work um but you know in clue
there are various different attached
cells that we might want depending on
whether it's you know I mean I would
imagine and I don't know if this is
correct that you know that this could
have a different attached cell from for
something like um you know
right I mean there would have to be some
you know recognition you know some
identifier that says that this is you
know a plain graphic versus the output
of plot is there an actor indication and
the I mean a certainly indication at the
level of the front end whether those
indication at the level those symbolic
expression I'm not sure I mean you know
if I looked at the boxes I could
probably tell you whether it was or not
well we can clearly hunt but you know I
you know if we wanted different attach
cells I would do something that would
make it crystal clear that this came
from of his function rather than what's
that hmm what's that a bunch of points I
understand but it's compressed in that
way yes that's just a matrix okay what's
all this stuff here that's some themed
stuff leaking in I think okay okay one
of my wishlist items is to clean up the
options of the viz function since they
aren't quite as verbose well okay but
but so one of the things we can
certainly do is we can assume that we
know what what the source of the graphic
was and that we can adjust the we can
sort of softly adjust the drawing tools
just like we adjust the suggestions bar
based on what the graphic where the
graphic came from right I mean and it
may be that you don't even want to do it
you know graphics versus plot but you
know based on other signals like does it
have axes in it well just based on that
which is the sort of thing that the
suggestions bar does I believe yes okay
but so okay so then it's alright so
there's no graphic which the red disc is
much bigger in your notebook than it was
when I sent it so I'm not sure what's
okay but oh so there's let's just get
the bigger or win right that oh that's
the cell that doesn't open there's
nothing there okay so let's write down
do we already have this information
already in another another place the
list of what we what we are trying to
achieve with the new drawing tools did
we already make that list anybody no not
that I know of
I'm sure I did that already but okay but
let's let's go ahead and make the list
okay all right so add bling to plots
that seems to be one thing that one
wants to do okay just save this
hold on anybody know where I'm saving
these nope I do not okay I'm going to
create a folder for drawing tools okay
adding labeling to plots so one of the
issues there is when you add a label you
often want to point to a particular
thing you know various kinds of
constrain drawing are needed okay
actually there's a zero thing which is
place text etc in a canvas okay
presenter tools okay right right that's
a very that that's like I'm making a you
know I start a presentation here I say
new um new presenter notebook boom and
then I do one of these and I say create
and now I think I had okay now what I
want to do is I want to start typing you
know what am i typing here that's not
what I wanted at all I want so let's say
I want a a section here but actually I
don't want a section here I want instead
why is that typing slowly oh don't tell
me this is still slow whatever I just
want a to put down I am drawing a
graphic type thing here and I want to
put my words as a soup all over this all
over this canvas am I making sense
yeah did you understand what I'm saying
I understand what you're saying I think
you have very different ideas of
presentations than I do but somebody
needs to report that bug I click there I
got that Matt do you have that I clicked
in here
I picked there after just selecting the
text tool okay okay oh god it doesn't
even work so anyway so this is that is
supposed to be but it's not working
typing text in there I'm making sense
right you understand what I'm saying yes
I mean it probably did work but not in
the most useful way well in a way that I
can't see it is not a useful way I mean
this is try dragging out a rectangle my
god whoa it it just it just crashed it
did wow that was spectacular
hasn't done that in a long time okay
well that's not very pleasing who um oh
don't tell me this thing is also not
logging into the cloud properly no not
that bug again Matt you've seen this bug
I don't have donkey tools up that's not
the excuse okay with us no yeah I'm with
us yeah I mean I don't deal with this
dialogue I could yeah fine I know you
don't deal with this dialogue but you
deal with the cloud interaction yeah I
well okay okay well I could try that
again and we can see a crash again but
um you understand what I was trying to
do I was trying to do what you can do
trivially your industry firm texts I was
trying to put text somewhere in my
canvas is this okay and that's a that's
a really common thing to want to do you
define a size of canvas so the workflow
is define a size of canvas then place
objects in it and that will turn into
you know underneath that will become a
graphics of blah blah blah blah blah
with an image size right make sense um
okay
let's keep going here so that the use
cases that I know of place text in a
canvas scribble and arbitrary picture
okay that's in the in the category of
just use you know right I mean there's
two main workflows right one is create
something entirely from scratch and one
is markup something that pre-exists yeah
okay so let's mark those down so these
are really from scratch and these are
annotation okay so another thing another
thing we might want to do is create a
geometric image or diagram and in the
annotation section what we might also
want to do is tweak a diagram by moving
stuff around yep okay um okay what other
use cases do we know of on the
annotation side you want to be able take
something like list plots and select one
or two points and make them bigger or
colored in some way so a modification of
a generated content so that's changing
styles a generated modifying elements of
a generated plot which I think is very
similar to add labeling to plots but
modifying elements actually maybe it
isn't the same thing because that's
easier I mean one of the issues with
adding labeling is yes actually actually
this is a better way to think about it
labeling could be done with call-out etc
right actually that's a much better way
to do it because one of the issues we've
had here um yeah okay this is in fact
stupid and that this is one of the
long-term issues is that you say I would
have put an arrow to that point right
but then somehow you regenerate the plot
and the arrow is gone
right you want to capture the
modification right but so then this is
not obvious how you would do that here
because it's a question of how do you
write back the style change to the plot
so I'm saying because in in in John the
clones scenario we had something like um
you know let's say we had our list plot
array you know prime 20 or something
okay and now we want to pick that okay
so if I go in here I might be able to
select I know God knows how to do this
that point there okay now what can I do
at that point what Chris what can I do
right now at that point you should be
able to drag it what about can I change
its size right click it right click no
but if you have the palette open you
should be able to I mean if you can't
and that's you know an obvious yeah well
none of us know how to do this I mean
none of us you know that level of drill
down that I had to do that was pretty
weird okay so I've got that selected now
let us open the points and try dragging
the size and probably still did all of
them
I didn't do a squat it didn't do
anything doesn't make them disappear um
the opacity sets a zero some reason
why we have no idea but now we've not
selected the point so let's regenerate
this now okay so what I don't even
understand what that selection state is
does anybody understand that so so click
one of those points okay so now I've got
the opacity set what the hell it just
unselected what's it doing okay
why did it unselect that that's a
compound object a single point array and
the inspector may have never been
implemented for elements of an array all
right okay well let's pick the hole
right the whole array oh not click
outside the graphic now click
double-click inside and click once on a
point I did ok double click a point
well no no I've got to get into that
weird gray state which I don't
understand
that means the selections inside the
graphic okay so I single click one yep
okay now using spa there you go
magnificent well I've never known how to
do that before okay I mean whatever was
going on there was completely obscure in
terms of give me feedback about what was
happening or any of that stuff well so
it it may not be by design this code has
not been very actively maintained
there's gonna say that palette so far as
I know it hasn't been changed since
version six right okay well that's
fairly modern that was what 2004 or
something really was it that late to
take us that long to get version six out
okay in any case no matter didn't really
take that long I don't think so anyway
whatever okay so okay so the question
here is so now I've done this now I want
to regenerate my list plot and of course
it's gonna go away you have
you still have the modified version yeah
I understand but you know that this is
the question of how much of the
modification do you want to keep I mean
it's the same thing if I were to have
something like a list okay let's say I
have you know a list here range of 20
and I go through and I select that thing
there and I go to format and I say color
and I say purple right
well that's purple but now if I evaluate
it again it'll go away
this is but I think what we want for
plots is I mean okay so to be clear you
know one of the important things here is
that how do we put in this case here if
I want to say call-outs if I want
call-outs on these if I just map
call-out on to all of those okay
interesting
all right so now let's talk about that
case all right so let's say I want to
add to one point here I want to add a
call-out because I can imagine that
being a real thing is this okay but what
I ultimately want is to have that
reflected in the original list in the
underlying list right and so can I speak
for a moment yes okay so the two cases
we're looking at here you know are sort
of in some ways very similar you know
changing the style you know when you
made the points bigger we're just adding
a call-out you know so they're both
modifying the output of list plots
that said there are potentially very big
differences between them in that when
you change the size of the points that
was changing something that's sort of
deep in the output of the list plot and
tied into the structure that list plot
generated if you come through afterward
and add a call-out then potentially that
is possible to be done you're sort of in
a way that is outside of what list plot
actually generated and so it may be
pasta maybe easier to capture well I
don't think that's true cos plot style
as a way of annotated lis changing all
the sizes of the points so we've got a
similar issue here look at this case
okay you've got the viewpoint of this
thing right right and you know I can do
shift enter here and I will preserve
that viewpoint right but now if I want
the viewpoint I mean I guess I can I
mean if it's a better example is not to
do shift enter on that polyhedron but to
change it to a different polyhedron in
the input cell so if you change
octahedron to sphere okay I mean it will
still have that viewpoint when you do
the revaluation when didn't know it
didn't sorry okay
fine rotate it's because when you did it
it turned it into an input cell so if
you rotate that and then change it and
reevaluate
okay that's an interesting behavior so
in other words so that's an interesting
and not obvious
I mean it's boy what is that okay so
that that's a question of um there are
these cases where um okay so let's let
some principles here um when you've
tweaked an output then you overwrite it
do the options survive right now let's
look at a case of that another case of
that okay so if we do a random actually
have a question about this I don't know
how this will work but let's say I do
this um okay that's a certain size now
let's say I resize that and it should be
the same small size when you reevaluate
it is right so so what is preserved so
just just so I understand um basically
image size in the view options okay
image size and viewpoint um what else I
mean I'm assuming all the view whatever
you know which there's half a dozen of
but these are only preserved if the
graphic or graphic 3 is the only thing
in the output okay preserved if they are
top level if the graphic is top level in
the output
I mean to be perfectly honest this is
kind of a hack I mean it's very useful
hack but it's kind of a hack I mean so
in other words what you're telling me is
if I were to do the same thing here and
I were to say you know table this let's
say or whether I should work with this
comma three and then I were to resize
that one like that and then I were to
regenerate it won't won't keep it
correct right okay okay um break this
out ah so something else does thinking
about is the from a user point of view
rather than worrying about the
implementation is the reversibility
question because you can imagine with
that kind of rotation it'd be very easy
to expect to be able to go back to
something that says Joe dodecahedron
view point goes to whatever you menu
rotators you see you could recapture
what you did by hand in code but if you
look at your example from earlier about
the list plot there's an obvious problem
with that reversible which is you can't
get that information out well you could
but the question is what do you want
because what you might want is to get a
list plot 1 2 3 comma call out for so
you might that might be what you want
but you might want this plot of the
array of flying numbers with a map at
position 4 right so look look to me it
seems like the following is the case one
could imagine that the inspector here
can pick out the options
in some way that I mean just like the
the image inspector has a way of you
know picking out in the coordinates tool
for example and by the way look look
look look there was a bug there that
just came up when I hit the the image
inspector sense okay I can investigate
that okay so anyway we've got my wife I
dropped out while I was talking now I
don't know if I was I was in the middle
of anything useful when you lost me no I
don't know it depends what you were
saying okay so look this is a case where
whoops what the heck happened there that
this is a case you saw what it did there
it was a way of of pulling out of the
annotated object certain information is
this right well I mean I could imagine
just like here I could get pixel values
out I could imagine going into one of
these plots and being able to extract
you know being able to say for example I
mean there are most obvious things I
point at that point what are its
coordinates and we don't even have that
we have three we do hit period
okay what does that do I mean that gives
you a view into the coordinate system
for the graphic but it didn't copy
anything you can click okay
so you're saying a hit period whoops I
go into the graphic wait a minute what
does it say that when I am in the
graphic double-click to edit right yeah
so if you select if you mouse over the
crosshairs in the tools section of the
drawing tools palette I'm so nervous
about hitting this because it's gonna
cry fingers gonna crash everything it's
it's okay if you crash we have the
recording of the meeting and we'll have
Matt regenerate the notebooks right okay
um thanks okay okay so anyway so I got
that tool and so you click command C and
then it pastes and there's an annoying
bug bug okay snapping in what sense in
the sense well because if you hover
slightly away from the center point it
doesn't give you the point it gives you
the you know the slightly away yeah
which is kind of stupid right so I mean
there's a okay desires right um right
now it's making that functionality more
real to the key things right I on my
list for the new okay so look being able
to get data about something you see in a
graphic out so actually that's the thing
that breasts are working on last we can
get all of the options and then the
object itself okay right I mean so one
of the things that you see a lot in like
text editing apps like page layout sorts
of things is the ability to copy and
paste styles
yeah I've never been a big fan of that
right although that would be you know
potentially the you know one path for I
adjusted you know the point size and I
want to reuse that within plot style hmm
okay well look the next okay being able
to get data about something you see in a
graphic out that's the first step of you
know a graphic was generated you just
want to be able to interrogate that
graphic it's a purely information
gathering thing okay the next thing you
want to be able to do is which is again
rather simple is interactively change
the overall styling of the graphic right
which is pink is a is again a fairly
straightforward thing that is the
equivalent of changing viewpoint
changing size like existing viewpoint
size etc and that could be you know
change the plot theme through those
other kinds of things this um and
right so that's a
so that the next level would be okay
modify well add let's see add styling
etc to elements of the plot of the
graphic so that's that's the first time
okay so then eg eg wrap call out around
something right I mean I'm not sure that
rep collared around something is well I
mean so sorry talking about something
that would I'm saying I want to label
that point okay so insert a call-out
yeah okay that I mean I think that is
feasible you know and it is potentially
you know one of the ways of so we have
this thing where we've struggled to
figure out how to add call-outs to
general graphics without
you know killing performance things that
we like well that's a different issue
which would you write so god but but I
mean absolutely
you know the drawing tools could be you
know taught how to insert call-outs well
at least in okay then the final thing is
adding elements to a graphic I mean okay
adding elements to a graphic moving
elements in a graphic and then for that
matter deleting elements in a graphic
right
and when I say graphic we might want to
break that into the case of a plot
versus a pure disembodied graphics thing
is this right okay so let's look at
these what we want to distinguish in the
idea of moving and deleting elements
between elements that are purely
aesthetic like where the call-out is
versus moving the point itself which is
faking the data right right right right
another item would be aligning elements
and graphics things like snap to and
grids yep okay so hold on a second
aesthetic but I think that's a different
okay so wait a minute moving
ah let's say content elements
well add content elements to a graphic
but before that is basically add
aesthetic elements to a graphic
add or modify okay what do we mean by an
aesthetic element eg eg move the
position of a call-out or or legend
etc right which is different this is
this is moving content elements in a
graphic quotes fake the data obviously
that's not the real reason one might do
that but but you know that that's the
that's what that comes down to um okay
okay so these are really things these
are all things related to our first hour
yeah modifying modifying pre-created
graphics flash visualizations by the way
I don't think we're even talking about I
mean you see see that this there's other
things here like for example um if we
had a graph plot we might want to move
around a point in a graph see that's a
that's a quite separate thing that's a
oh boy I mean I think we're not
considering that at this time oops I
mean strictly speaking I'm not really
considering a lot of that stuff at this
time you know the first priority is to
get something that is more visible and
accessible yeah and not completely silly
in terms of what okay so okay so this is
modifying pre-created graphics but again
there is the completely different issue
of blank canvases okay this isn't maybe
we should break those apart I mean the
question is how do you get so we had a
thing did we not called create canvas
did that ever get added um it's still in
proto builds
look at it it never got completed oh
gosh okay okay so one piece that is the
create canvas so are you saying that's
in the prototype build there there's a
scribble version in the prototype build
that doesn't give you any choice but to
draw a line okay so let's take a look at
that this is so broken okay so now what
you're saying is and I don't know if
anyone's looked at this for some number
of months or possible years so I
evaluated it last week but that's about
it okay
okay well that was kind of nice maybe
that seems useful
to me I mean that that's so so they
outer boundary of that canvas how do I
resize so what does the outer boundary
mean yeah well that orange solid
boundary just means this is a special
graphic this this never got to the point
of going through graphic design but that
was the indication that I chose need
from the patient to that this is a
canvas well I like this I think this is
useful and I think that Sam
okay so so this will be a thing that is
the analog that might have a button in
presenter tools that then allows you to
start putting text in so this this is so
that's a that's a quite separate thing
this comes up as a scribble tool but you
want it to be able to have you know this
create canvas would have then an
attached cell presumably that lets you
or or a sidebar that lets you pick the
tool it's that right is it in the
general case yeah that seems sensible
right so okay all right so I mean that
okay so look let's let's imagine that
these are our two main design goals
modifying pre-created graphics and blank
canvases let's let's look at what we
didn't do there the thing we haven't
done there is creating geometric
diagrams okay which is a yet a separate
thing well I mean then we've also got
creating molecules and things like that
actually we've got R I mean there are
lots of domain-specific visual there are
graphics objects that we have these days
right okay but I mean the
Gammage case I personally think that you
know one of the use cases for that will
be well okay so one case that we might
want to have if we say um what is it
geometric scene okay so let's imagine
how I don't know why I'm doing this in
the prototype I mean let me just pick an
example here all right
so let's say we have can we have a more
non-trivial example okay there's a
non-trivial example okay so let's go
here um okay so this is what I would
presumably wants here I generate that
scene and then I want to pick up C and
move it around
with that constraint Chris that would be
for you
right oh yeah so maybe you could just
show us because that this is another
case that I think is of interest right
is the and okay so there's um hold on a
second so this is blank canvases and
then there's geometric drawing of which
one possibility would be to take an
object like that and modify it you know
and then so one case here is modify with
underlying constraints and another case
is draw from scratch and maybe those are
combine a ball and draw from scratch
involves a lot of snapping I would think
this makes sense to people
I mean eg um okay let's have a quick
look at some comments on the live stream
and then Kristin maybe we could go to
take a look at your at your demo okay
and and I want an understanding of how
what you've done relates to this kind of
geometric assertion language but let's
look at some things on the live stream
here Karl comments she often looks at
images that are many megabytes and the
front end doesn't perform well with a
dozen images of that size in a notebook
I don't know what anybody who might want
to comment on that whether the 64 bit
stuff will have affected that or what
the reason for a notebook to grind to a
halt when there are many big images in
it is I can't speak definitively on that
no I mean file size comes in the you
know the size of the boxes comes into
play the 64 bit should alleviate that if
there were a memory institutions but I'm
not sure that there are I mean I've
certainly routinely you know I I used
you know notebooks as scrapbook so to
speak and put images and lots and lots
of images and it works up to a point and
then one of the issues is inserting in
the middle of the notebook gets slow but
that's something we should actually ask
you may about given that the 64 bit
stuff is being added let's ask them to
assess that I'll mention one other
things that I've noticed
by looking over someone's shoulder they
were interacting with an image that had
far more resolution than they thought it
did they thought they were working with
a 512 by 512 image when really it was
yeah or K by 4k or something yeah right
well and the fact that we don't give any
indication of that is interesting you
know you have no way to know that it's a
super resolution image and actually
there's a certain argument that in this
tool that it should say something about
the size of the image it probably
doesn't Rosie I button yeah yeah I mean
but it's not I mean it's one level down
and well what we could do is have a
hover indicate the size of the image but
maybe that would be annoying maybe it
would be worth putting in if it's a
hyper resolution image and not worth it
otherwise you only care if it's
substantially different than its
displayed yes yes right I think that
will be an interesting thing to do to
have something which gives you the
resolution if it is if it is not
self-evident I mean in other words if I
do an image if I make an image here that
is like a an eight by eight image okay
and then I go and I blow it up it's
self-evident what that size is right the
only case that isn't self-evident is
when the thing is hyper resolution
that's something for shorties group to
suggest I was gonna say long long ago we
had the thing that would showed up on
the cell bracket to show you how much
memory each cell took
yeah I'm not actually suggesting we
bring that back but does the status area
do anything now it does not that we
could and I'd say we doesn't give the
dimensions or something yeah well so the
main main point there is just know what
you have if it's very big or even just
showing percentage even if it's smaller
I think is useful fifty percent you know
five hundred percent what do you mean
well it's showing the percentage scale
instead of the pixels as just as useful
yeah I don't know I mean maybe to you
right I mean it they're right I mean if
you right-click on does it show up under
magnification does its percentage again
yeah yeah but probably that's a
different magnification that's not the
magnification that's not the implicit
pixel rendering sighs that's the
magnification in the notebook that's not
the that's not the amount that the image
was D magnified to display it would be
right if it reflected it'd be the same
thing right if you right-click on it and
says it's a fifty percent yeah that's
the same as dragging it to fifty percent
well that seems unconvincing really okay
okay okay so that's the local
magnification yeah inside of image
inside the image object okay ha okay
well anyway so look there's there's
something for user assistance which
would be a combination of the following
things one is maybe you know maybe
there's something in the cell you know
some cell bracket thingy that shows you
large memory cells
maybe there's something which shows you
the size of the image either on click or
somewhere now this the cell could have a
separate magnification from the image
I'm not sure how that interact right I
like it attached to the image seems
better or on hover you're related to the
image
right okay let's let's go on from this
point but that that's something for user
assistance okay Matt if you're dealing
with notes here yes
okay Mohammed says I noticed that text
grid is not typeset if I deploy an
interface as a cloud object with text
Critias output I'm pressing a button in
that interface is that an issue with
text grid in the cloud I think that's a
that's a completely separate set of
people but Matt that would actually be
for you does text grid work in the cloud
well text grid is the textual version of
you know text grid is expected to grid
works in the cloud
although I think one of the points here
is that this is editable right in cloud
this is one this is a giant feature I
know I would love to have in the cloud
and I've yeah but this is also relates
to table view and so on so I'm not quite
sure what that what the complaint I mean
if I say cloud publish that it should
render just fine I use grids in the
cloud all the time
what
oh I see I see I see percent wasn't the
right thing yeah okay next up George is
asking about high school geometry
constructions that's what we're about to
talk about sander is asking we make
changes like adding lines can you also
get the code back like the original code
with an epilogue or prologue added
interesting so that's an interpolation
between the that's sort of an
interpolation between some of these
cases so the idea of adding an epilogue
is yeah so this one you know
that thing here you know could work by
adding an epilogue but certainly this
modifying
yeah adding styling can't work that way
in our current set-up right correct and
adding elements you know by adding an
epilogue may also not work depending on
you know especially if you start doing
things like changing the Z order yes
well so if your plot range is set to
something like show wall then am i right
in thinking that epilogue isn't gonna
affect that good don't remember off the
top of my head I mean there are you want
it to expand to show the whole thing I
guess yeah I mean probably what I would
do more likely is you know if we start
with you know the output of plot and we
start drawing stuff on top of it that
what we draw would be marked up in some
way
well that really it allows us to
separate it from look we've got two
reasons to want layering immediately one
is layers are useful and you can switch
them on and often things another is
being able to imagine doing an
optimization where you can leave you
know in a dynamic you could leave one
layer fixed and just have all the action
you know all the game characters running
around another layer would that make
sense yes although I don't think you
need players for that well the
alternative is to use object graphics
but that's a whole different
construction it's easier actually if you
do it with layers you don't have to have
handles if you just structure your
dynamics properly you don't need layers
for good perform right that's what I
meant
but and how would you structure them you
what is object graphics well it means
you have a handle okay you're mario has
a you know it's like a Dom element type
thing it just has a you know it's the
way that basically games have worked
forever as long as you have dynamics
closely wrapped around the things you
want to change only those things will be
affected and the other things are
essentially constant
although if you have 100 characters you
know cartoon characters or whatever you
don't necessarily 100 dynamics if you
know maybe more efficient to update them
all at once yeah but I don't think layer
solves our problem probably not okay in
the final 2 might would be fresh or need
what's that
would you just have to wrap them and
refresh with and then the appropriate
option no okay
call on the live stream that makes
another point which is we should think
about touchscreens and styluses which
we're actually not thinking about mostly
because
well hmm maybe we are I mean a stylist
is just a the whole point about a
stylist is it makes something like you
know the scribble tool more natural well
in depending on the stylist it gives you
you know they can read how hard you're
pressing down and adjust thickness based
on that as you're drawing sure yeah but
that's okay I mean I think that's a
luxury item for the kinds of things
we're doing all right let's take a look
at Tom Chris's demo here shall I let you
share Chris yeah go ahead okay see my
screen yep okay so this is a prototype
that I wrote I think ten years ago now
and it imports a GSP geometers sketchpad
file and essentially emulates the kind
of constraint solving that geometers
sketchpad does which i divined by
observing how geometers sketchpad works
so this is for example a centroid
construction here is this is essentially
this is what if you imported a GSP file
for this cow button okay yeah so you can
you can grab any object here and you
know it behaves okay dad McDonald who's
the compare this of what you've seen
with what we now have well so the the
problem with doing something like this
for us is if there's a oh my the the
problem with doing something like this
with with our stuff is if it's if the
the centroid is defined to be some point
that has some other relations it has to
satisfy
um it's not so simple obviously if it
has too many relations you can't do it
right so it's for something like this I
think James has tested out putting in
geometric scene geometric scene inside
and manipulate and it kind of works some
of the time so I what is kind of works
all the time mean and why does that
happen in other words that this is if we
look at the specification here you know
obviously it's syntactically different
but it's the same type of thing right
something is the midpoint of this and
that etc etc so this is very similar to
a geometric scene right I guess what I'm
saying is when it kind of works some of
the time is it'll work on a simple and
I've seen it would probably work on this
one other thing is the kind of
constraints generated by you know the
geometric scene are tailored for for use
in that in fine minimum which might not
necessarily be optimized for directly
fine so there would have to be
retargeting of those constraints for
this right but theoretically yes this
should be doable with with this so I
mean Chris you have some some language
here that describes the constraints
right right yes we see that language do
you did you make a list of the
primitives oh I don't I don't know you
know here's examples is point on object
I guess that's the main thing here
there's midpoint yeah okay have you seen
the new geometric primitives hmm
some of them okay yeah so there's a
significant restriction and geometers
sketchpad you cannot add multiple
constraints per object so you in
diameter sketchpad you create a
construction by drawing every time you
draw it every time you every time you
create a constraint that's coupled with
drawing an object so there's a wonder
one correspondence between constraints
and objects you can't go back and say
add this constraint to these existing
out
which means you cannot have multiple
constraints apply to a single object dan
can you comment on that yeah
that me that that is vastly simpler than
what we're dealing with right right yeah
so Chris you're saying that you can't
have a point that's the midpoint of two
different lines now because you create
that constraint by saying here's these
two points give me a point which is the
midpoint of those two points right so
the the can't go back after the fact and
add another midplane constraint to it
right that's the you know the magic of
our geometric scene stuff is we can do
that and it's yeah it is not
particularly easy which is why things
like that would probably not work in
this sort of right so what you're
telling me is there's a set of things
which are reasonable to do in constrain
drawing which are these one constraint
things geometric scene is more general
than that right okay and it may or may
not be possible to unravel something I
mean it's like a triangular ization of
some set of constraint equations or
something can you unravel it in two or
maybe it's even more extreme than that
can you unravel it into one constraint
per object or not if not well maybe we
don't do interactive drawing on that
right eh okay so anyway look first step
what I would say is at some point in the
in the kind of a geometric scene
computation process we create a
dependency graph uh to look for for four
cycles for so if it doesn't have a cycle
if it's a simple graph right it should
be doable right okay well fine so I
think that the step is to take what
Chris has here and if that's useful or
if you have a direct way to do it to
take these you know tree dependency
things and just make constrain drawing
from them okay and then and then figure
out if it isn't a tree what can we do
because in
some cases it will be rigid you can't
move it right right I mean this
particular case for rather obvious
reasons is very you know is very floppy
um ok Chris did you want to show
anything else on this well I have I have
a number examples but I don't know I
mean there's a there's a trace facility
to which is useful and geometers
sketchpad so I can select this point and
say trace and now I move this and you
can see how produces a parabola that's
cool so so what does that really mean
what is that really doing that's
sampling some number of times per second
where that is yeah I just it's just
leaving it you know what do you mean
it's just marking each position where
the point was yeah but but you're moving
it and it's sampling your mouse
positions at some frequency yeah I mean
every time it updates essentially well
how's the poor users know what what it
means to say every time it updates
well yeah this is a prototype so you
might want to do something more exact
fair enough action production okay any
other demo items here these are
beautiful by the way yeah I mean nothing
pantograph you know the kind of the same
okay okay well cool please send this to
Dan I mean and okay why don't you unsure
okay so let's go back here to our okay
let's talk about blank canvases to begin
with okay because I think they may be an
easier case okay so I think for Noah an
early target would be to produce a
reasonable you know attached tool for
blank canvases sure um let's talk about
what that needs to be able to do okay
and whether there are actually two cases
and I don't know and this is a Jeremy
partly a Jeremy question and so on you
know there is the case
of just freeform drawing okay drawing
with lines drawing with koala God you
know actually drawing a picture like the
one I did here that's case number one
the other case is essentially freeform
text layout which I claim is an
important case as well anybody want to
comment on that
I don't necessarily view them as
different cases all right well if we
have drawing does that mean we need
editing to to go back and reselect what
you did and modify it sure but we I mean
it's not complicated I think I mean adds
to it quite a bit it depends what the
tools we have right every I mean Noah
has been prototyping a Bezier tool so
illustrator also think about it's
essentially the pen tool do you want to
show what you've done yes okay okay can
you go ahead and share them yes let me
just find it first okay right
okay is not that it is that this is the
correct version so you can just create
Bezier paths right so explain what what
happened here so that little button at
the top is the thing that initiates the
pen is that right so if I press it again
I'll get another pen no yeah yeah and if
you deselect it and reselect it then you
can draw more parts you can also close
them as well which is quite nice
so what is this relative to what so so
we have not had such an object before is
that right well I mean it's yeah it's
it's it's a Bezier curve but there's not
a tool that creates no I understand it
but that wasn't part of the drawing
tools palette of before no this is
incorrect it's cool so to show it again
bring bringing that I mean so for
example Jeremy this is probably a fairly
familiar object set of fact yeah yeah it
is yeah useful thing related is a you
take a the path that you sketch out and
convert it to a Bezier it's right so
interpolation of some some arbitrary
path and kind of fit it which is pretty
useful if you just it's kind of like
pencil to path kind of tool which means
that smiley face you drew previously
you'd be able to sort of go back and
change some points yeah sure yeah which
makes smoothes out everything when
that's really nice to be honest you know
when illustrator first came out and they
first introduced these things I had a
really hard time understanding you know
what how one used this multi control
point e-type thing but obviously it's a
simpler version in pages pages oh nine
they've now sort of changed it but it
was it was essentially just this um and
it was it was pretty obvious how to use
it
that is nicer than the original
illustrator thing so that little pivot
II thing is that's determining the
orientation of the curve is that correct
yes it's the tangent points right I see
that's pretty obvious but what about the
length of that the length of that bar
what does that mean okay so those are
the two so if I if I click here and just
create like a corner what that's doing
is just creating three points one on top
of the other mm-hmm and then when I drag
it separates them so that is the
location of the two control points
essentially so as you as you elongate
that thing how does it change what's
going on and when you not elongated if
you pull on yeah yeah you can you I get
it what does that do oh I see that is
the control point
yeah okay and then I pulled with two
others one is that it lets you go back
and edit these points and then the other
one is that it goes back it gets you
edit the control points which actually
Brett and I have we've got a version but
it's just sort of stuck in an event
handler hasn't been made into one that
can just work on graphics any graphic
okay very nice all right why don't you
unsure
okay okay so look I think what comments
do we have about the direction to go
with this I mean we just have to make
this obvious and that that's really just
a graphic design UX type challenge and
it does not want to look like you know
the cockpit of the concorde or something
which is what i view this as looking
like well well the problem with that is
that it shows you everything at once
even the stuff that's grayed out so that
I I think that the thing the thing that
you want all the time is the tools at
the top and then you just want the the
contextual controls that apply to the
object you selected so if it's a line
and you don't need to know why did we do
it this way Chris originally why did we
have this fully displayed thing did we
know I'm abs or something at that time
where was this built this was built for
version 3 is that right no six six yeah
I can't say I certainly if I were doing
it today I would I would have an
inspector that only shows the relevant
things I don't know if that interface
functionality it didn't exist then or
why did it this way okay you may have
been you know step too far for those
dynamics at the time or something okay
all right
so so then the suggestion is I mean what
do we think about the single click
double click motif for this for this
tray up here the locking would double
click I think once you learn about it
it's useful but most people will just be
confused by it as you were earlier in
this meeting I think with the textual
right so do you think it will be better
in modern times just to have the things
show that one is the one that's pressed
and you know if you don't want it then
unpress it rosalie especially if it's
right up next to the graphic that that
seems like a quite an obvious indication
no uh what do you think
yeah I would agree yeah I mean my one
question I mean my one concern is you
know if we have the bezzie a true wall
how you end one Bezier and start the
next let's not worry about Betty Bezier
is an advanced case that's really cool
but I think it's probably in the in the
more tools area how do we do it with the
polyline at the moment is it just Enter
I think it's double click double click
OK I mean I would assume it'd be enter
um I'm not sure you have keyboard
control at that point I mean I'm not
sure the keyboard isn't doing other
things while you're drawing a polyline
you mean yes I'm not sure that that
contextualizes the keyboard to that to
the graphic drawing I'm not sure you
have to look at that but I okay I mean I
I also think there has got to be some
indication yeah I mean look these things
here arguably okay to me you know the
number of times I draw a circle is small
compared to the number of times I draw
an arrow put text in draw a scribble
could could you try the scribble that's
eyes wondering whether scribble should
be smooth well yeah it doesn't it should
be that was on the agenda of things to
do I never got it done yeah it gets back
to that conversion to Bezier but it's a
you know you have to figure out what it
to what extent right well you might want
you know an advanced thing I mean we
might want the basic tools and then the
advanced tools so you can hide multiple
tools behind the same thing so for
example instead of having to have all
those different shapes you can have one
shape tool and when you press down on it
it gives you the other ones and like I
said there were three pens well when you
press down in it you could get three
buttons fair enough right mean each
one's essentially a pop-up menu yeah
exactly right especially if the tools
are a tab but next to the graphic issue
definitely just this single a double
click behavior should go away the reason
for that originally was we we have
existing graphics and we don't want you
know the tool to be set to a circle tool
when you're just trying to click on a
graphic you you want it always to revert
to the selection tool that's why it was
implemented this way Noah did you
understand that comment yes but if the
tools are attached to the graphic than
you know for each graphic what you know
what tool is in effect that's not gonna
be a point of confusion oh I see what
you're saying okay yeah I mean I find
the fact that this is the selection tool
and that it sort of looks a bit like an
arrow is pretty damn confusing and I
know what that one is what's that one
that's an eyedropper for selecting a
style and applying it to something else
let's see it it's a it's okay um okay
okay so now Noah the the I mean thinking
about touch can you do the thing yeah
you can do that thing you just touch it
and it's it opens out I guess yes I mean
the way for example illustrates that it
does it is that um you just click and
hold so each
I think each I think I'm right in saying
each button you can do that with has
essentially like a little sort of arrow
in the bottom right hand corner Tim
using the straight so don't you is that
how it does it and then essentially if
you click down on it and hold it for a
second you get the options yeah it's got
a little like triangle in the corner
yeah that's it okay I think people would
be like expecting to see that I reckon
they'd know what that means yeah I mean
our our user base that might use this is
a little won't necessarily have used
illustrator know bowling pages does the
same thing yeah fair enough fair enough
okay especially if some have it in some
don't like oh okay well there's more to
those tools and those ones all right so
let's walk through this so in the in the
blank canvas case we think we have some
understanding I mean you know it needs a
bunch of UX and design work to come up
with something reasonable here um and I
think Noah should just go ahead and try
and do that and the goal would be that
we would have either you know in either
will have a function create canvas which
by the way when we have that function it
could have options that specify things
about what tools come up with the canvas
right and that you might say well
nobody's going to do it but actually
that yes they are going to do it because
it um I wasn't gonna say because because
they might be preparing some environment
for other users so to speak and they
will be perfectly happy to you know
let's say in some educational setting
they would shut down all the particular
um you know all but particular tools and
so on so that's stored in the graphics
object itself I mean so that has to be
left over once you've created the canvas
and made edits you want it to stay in
that state
good point think that's difficult okay
so it has to be in the box structure of
the canvas yeah right it has to be in
there somewhere
okay okay lots of things that you can
imagine create canvas doing like you
know being able to take the non editable
background sort of thing yes that's
right it should be able to take a
background yeah she'll be able to take
an image rights or another graphic or
whatever yeah it's a good point that's a
very good point so that you can do
tracing and things like that right and
arguably then create canvas would have
to choose whether to actually preserve
that okay so given that I said create
canvas then I have that background image
there what does what actually comes out
if I were to take the input form of that
I would see if I wanted so one of the
considerations of this is the thing I
get out I should be able to shift enter
evaluate it and it should be some
graphics object is that right
this is well I mean it's gotta be a
graphics object we know it's a graphics
object right well I mean the question is
you know is it a graphics object with
had graphics or is it maybe it's still
any because it could be a canvas object
that just type sets as graphics if you
grab a graphics you know from some other
source than what it wraps canvas around
it as soon as you do something to it
well if you did create canvas of
graphics create canvas of plots actually
what would be nice there is if we had a
canvas object we could have sub values
of that which extract different kinds of
things but instead I think you want to
start with a plot right you don't want
it kind of the user to pre think I want
to make a canvas out of this fly you
just start with a plot you touch it you
want things to work sure but it could
still come out as a you know as some
kind of canvas object which then could
have why is my call graphics outputs
would be pre wrapped with canvas in that
case no no but that's then this you
would be able to go back from here if
you wanted to and I'm not saying this is
necessarily the right way to do it by
the way my typing is just slowed down
immensely which is probably because of
dynamics and the drawing tools which is
really kind of horrifying or something
something from Noah's but you're not you
don't have any of his at the moment no
that was remote through um whatever the
output is is well you probably wanted to
support create canvas of dynamic of X in
order to pipe that into a symbol what I
might want to create canvas of dynamic
of some symbol and then if you for
example add another cell dynamic of
symbol you'd see it refreshing as he
grew that's not how I would imagine that
working John my
there's that you would essentially be
drawing on top of an animation or
something
I don't understand that one depends
whether you what the question is if you
have a purpose do we use this you don't
want to have to be able to the only way
to reuse it being to do shift return on
what you've gone yeah you want to be
able to suck data out of the canvas as
it is being drawn well I'd be satisfied
if there was a lag if it wasn't kind of
absolutely real-time but yes there ought
to be some way of getting the thing
you've drawn without having to paste it
into an input cell right so in other
words you want to be able to
parameterize the content of the canvas
you want to be able to essentially bind
that to a variable X that you use
elsewhere yeah so I might do some
processing more that would be except I'm
so put off because my typing is slow
here create canvas of object of dynamic
of X and then you have somewhere else a
dynamic of X that is doing something or
alternatively you are you know you have
a slider that is containing dynamic of X
and that's changing inside the visible
canvas okay so so um by the way Ethan on
the live stream says study the Sketchup
or Mac OS for drawing insights um so
that was probably a homework for Noah if
he doesn't already know that I haven't
come across it now okay well there
probably exists it might be maybe I can
maybe it just no it's probably what is
that oh well I was gonna say sounds like
a third party app which I'll have a look
at okay fine um
okay uh all right so let's just review
for one second we're gonna have to move
to another meeting which by the way is
also gonna be live-streamed you know I
don't want to miss that meeting yeah
that meeting is important but but um
okay so I just want to come back to a
couple of things here so I think you
know for Noah what we need to work on is
this canvas thing I don't know to what
extent the symbolic wrapping of a canvas
is the right thing it may be it may be a
good place to start um I'd really do
like the idea of being able to
interrogate the graphic beyond just
saying what's the input form pull pieces
out of it and it's an interesting
question whether you know we have not
used sub values of graphics ever know
and we could they could be used to do
non-trivial extraction of stuff I mean
right now you know you have a graphic
you want to find what you know the
access labels and the graphic are or
something it's a it's a messy thing well
if it's options it's not so messy anyway
that's the thing to think about
the other big thing to think about is is
the retrieval of information so so okay
the the big things I think that are
problems here ah does you know are you
merely drawing on top of the graphic as
a layer or are you associating your
annotations with actual elements in the
graphic did that make sense and the
simpler case is obviously what we are
talking about now with canvases where
you're essentially drawing on a layer on
top of the graphic and the graphic
itself does not change but the drawing
tools are obviously supporting changing
the underlying graphic
right problem with changing the
underlying graphic is what happens to
that changed underlying graphic you know
it's it's now been separated from
whatever code it was that generated the
graphic now doesn't generate the graphic
anymore you know these demos of scene
programming systems keep coming to mind
where you have the code next to the
scene you can change the code you see
the scene change you drag something in
the scene that coordinates and the code
changes I can imagine something like
that for like a plot output you select
it you get the drawing tools as well as
a plot expression and then when you do
something in the you know with the
drawing tools you see the plot
expression update and then well i'm
expressions though i mean most of those
scene drawing tools they have you know
very toy you know numbers of elements i
mean we're not talking about pictures of
i'm sure it's not an easy problem yeah
no no no but I'm talking about the UX I
mean it's a fine thing you know I've
seen some really nice things along those
lines even with where you move physical
objects and there's cameras watching
them and so on but those are for small
numbers of objects you know if you have
a picture some realistic graphic or even
a generated data graphic I don't see
that being well i'm thinking primarily
of the case where you have like you
produce a plot and then you put a call
out on a point and you want that to be
reflected in the plot come in yes I
understand but imagine you had a million
points and you want to put a call-out on
one point it's an outlier and you want
to put a call out on that one point out
of a million that's a messy thing you're
not gonna be able to see those million
points in plain text how do you do that
I presume if it's just one point you
have like something like an index arrow
point I don't know what the syntax is no
but I mean my why do you want to see the
actual code of the graphic
because because it is a way of
indicating to you that you can copy it
and use it again but there might be
other ways to indicate that yeah I mean
if you're going to produce an infant
expression which is manageable then it's
it's it's got to be a small expression I
don't know maybe not really I mean it
doesn't really it can be look it can be
programmatically manageable but not sort
of edit manageable yeah okay yeah but I
think the idea I mean the fundamental
idea is how do you get the core
expression you know like for example
okay the core the case of adding a
call-out or styling some points okay
let's imagine that you've got a plot and
you've got some person who wants to
manually and but by the way we're
talking about plots but you know who
knows a geo bubble chart or something I
don't know what you know we need to also
be thinking about these much more
derived visualization things like let's
say a geo bubble chart um you know let's
imagine that you've got your geo bubble
chart then you want to click on the
cities that you think you know you made
the geo bubble chart of some Perez some
characteristic of whether you want to
live in these cities or something okay
and then you want to click different
bubbles well let's imagine you would
take that geo bubble chart you want to
erase the cities that for whatever
reason once in your criteria you don't
want to live in them so you want to edit
your charts to leave only the bubbles
around the cities that you actually care
about okay then the question would be
what is the output from that you know
what you would like as the output is to
treat that you know is to just list you
know is to just get a list of those
cities out anything other than that is
much less useful right so in other words
okay so here's a way to think about it
there is underlying data that generated
the plot and I mean this is something
we've come up over and over again that
we need to have a linkage between the
underlying data and and then this
becomes essentially an edit of the
underlying data instead of a mere edit
of the graphics derived from the other
line
does that make sense yeah so I mean to
me what I'm imagining is that there is a
you know how expensive is it to keep
enough information and for example list
plot to know what the underlying data
was like
and how do we do that if we were to keep
enough information and some tagging then
in this sub value model you could edit
the plot you could ask for a sub value
which asks for the underlying data and
there it is your data set does that data
set has a caching mechanism that stores
the data corresponding to what you see
in the display in an efficient way
okay well that's something perhaps to
learn from four plots but I mean if we
could do that then whatever editing you
do here is actually editing of the
underlying you know you can then extract
from that they under like the the edited
underlying data which seems like a good
way to do it
I mean the hard part is figuring out how
to do it efficiently by the way somebody
is asking is if this is just a Wolfram
language expression the answer is yes
can't we can we isn't there a thing that
says notebook how do you make her know
do notebook read of you might need to
evaluate notebooks just to see which the
object is you know this is driving me
crazy that it's doing so slowly but okay
the drawing tools that third one
can I just copy it like that I hope so
yeah okay and then what do I say no book
read nope okay book it yeah okay there
it is
so that's the box structure of that
thing which is not was that is that how
it was made or was it made at some
higher level it was by running Wolfram
language code yeah this was so there was
code run that output this box structure
which renders as that palette yes
correct
okay I mean it
particular code is written in terms of
like Pro and button and whatever and
then it's in the boxes and then save to
the pallet all right we should wrap this
meeting um I think so Matt can you make
sure to send these things out to all
relevant people um and nowhere I think
you've got you know some Direction here
maybe you can think about this stuff try
and start coming up with things yeah um
and for those on livestream were
interested we are about to go into a
meeting about missing data and the
handling of missing data and you're all
invited but it's gonna be a different
livestream and we'll be there about two
or three minutes okay
thanks all thanks for comments on the
livestream see you later